[Musique]
1977 la france n'a pas de pétrole mais
la télé a des idées c'est maintenant que
nous allons agir ensemble pour vérifier
quelque chose en pleine crise pétrolière
l'heure est aux économies d'énergie et
les gia lie aux économies d'énergie les
français doivent moins consommer et quoi
de mieux que la télé pour faire passer
le message en direct roger gicquel
demande aux téléspectateurs d'éteindre
chez eux toutes les lumières inutiles
ce n'est pas sans une certaine émotion
que je vais éteindre cette lumière est
au même moment michel chevalet le
journaliste scientifique de tf1 se
trouve dans un centre de distribution
edf sa mission vérifier sur ce cadran la
variation de consommation d'électricité
des français nous attendons votre feu
vert pour voir cette aiguille se
déplacer dans ce sens là c'est à dire
que les français consomment au moins ou
autrement dit à ce moment-là l'edf sera
en surproduction roger gicquel donnent
l'exemple ambiance tamisée sur le
plateau du journal
top départ les français aussi éteignent
leurs lumières
c'est très net l'aiguillât dépasser le
zéro et commence à grimper allègrement
les milliers de kilowatts 50 millions de
kilowatts puissante 150 et l'éguille
continue de monter nous sommes à 150
milliers de kilowatts et bien c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation d'une
ville comme nancy ou nice vous voyez que
ce n'est pas du tout du tout négligeable
au bout de quelques minutes l'expérience
prend fin l'aiguillé se stabilise un peu
au dessus des 150 milliers de kilowatts
45 ans plus tard en 2022 en pleine
guerre en ukraine le message reste le
même il faut consommer moins d'énergie
bruno le maire ministre de l'économie a
appelé tous les français à baisser la
température dans leur logement
[Musique]